to the extraordinary
meeting of is
for the submissions for the stormwater
bylaw consultation
are we about to go live we are live
thank you
right we have our
first submitter as megan justice
from the h w richardson group
welcome megan
can you hear me
down the bottom
[Music]
um can you please unmute yourself
and um you have the floor
there she is welcome megan
hello everybody
thanks
for letting me attend your uh zoom
meeting today
i'm sitting up in dunedin and it's been
um
raining all day here so it might make
you a little bit jealous
can you hear me all right yes uh you've
got you've got the 10 minutes for the
submission and uh you can either do five
of your submission and five questions or
use it as you want to
okay thank you
um i haven't really got i've got about
four points to make on the draft
stormwater by law overall
and i'm here representing um the
richardson group
who own quite a few industrial
properties
in the district so obviously they will
be impacted by some of the undertakings
required under this stormwater by-law
in general terms
they are you know happy with the bylaw
and the intents and purposes of it
improving the water quality is always
front and center and it's pretty
important
they do realise that so the comments
that i have
are primarily to do with the
practicalities of it and some of the
work that may be required in order to
comply with it and whether or not the
time frames will be practical
so
i'll dive straight into my first comment
that relates to clause
5.3
and that clause says
from the date of commencement of this
by-law no person may discharge directly
or indirectly regulated stormwater into
the public stormwater network without
fire
approval my understanding is and this
may have been updated but when i looked
at the bylaw it was proposed to be
come into full force on the 1st of july
of this year
um so i was interested to know if
what the process is around
obtaining this prior approval for
stormwater discharges particularly from
higher law industrial sites
and how that process is expected to roll
out and firstly whether or not the
council has a database of the properties
and they will
let the property owners know if their
property is
one of these identified properties or
whether that's an undertaking that for
instance the richmond group needs to do
themselves
um and i am aware that
obtaining approval may require the
installation of
stormwater management devices or
interceptors and the like
to improve stormwater quality
if required on some sites
and
you know that might take some time as
well i know from experience in the
industry that it's
the civil engineering industry is it
a state of gridlock at the moment things
just don't happen that quickly because
there's a resourcing problem
so yeah i'll be interested to know if
there is some lenience in terms of time
frames if the first july is still going
to be the commencement date
for the bylaw
um so that was
my comments on clause 5.3
my comment on
next comment relates to
laws 5.5 and that
requires an erosion and sediment control
plan and i think this is just a
fairly easy tidy up that could be
undertaken in the bylaw
at the moment the way it's worded is
that for any development of any site
and that could be almost anything
um
the landowner is required to submit an
erosion and sediment control plan
there's quite a lot of work involved in
it and an erosion and sediment control
plan and they're very valuable tools if
you are
undertaking
earthworks of a significant quality or
are undertaking earthquakes
near a waterway well that obviously
washes into the stormwater network so i
just thought i think the intention of
pullus 5.5 is to
tie it back to a term that's defined
in section 4 of the by-law which is the
term development
and that
and if you read that
definition that says development in
relation to any land means altering of
stormwater runoff characteristics of the
land
including including stormwater drainage
works
so my
suggestion is that
there is a clear link
from clause 5.5 back to that definition
of development
just so it's
that clause only relates to the works
described in the term development
clause 6.1
again i think this is just a minor point
six clause 64.1 relates to pollution
prevention
and it
subfloors e of that
clause it talks about
construction of a new roof or spouting
or replacement of existing roots and
spouting with material that's likely to
cause
nuisance or pollution to the stormwater
system
um and some
materials are listed in that laws of the
bylaw
for instance copper lead asbestos
but um
you know as a
potentially as a lay person people
wouldn't know what other
potentially contaminating or polluting
products might be so i if a
comprehensive list of all the ones that
are available to builders in new zealand
which may not be
any additional ones to what you have
listed there but if there could be a
comprehensive
list that's updated regularly it will
just help the
end user to identify when products were
not suitable for those purposes
and i also wondered if this was
something that was picked up in the
building act process the building
consent process as well
i'm not sure about that but i would
assume that
for instance you wouldn't get a building
consent to
use copper or lead on your building
these days
you definitely wouldn't get it for
asbestos
and then my final comment relates to
clause 6.3
and influence 6.3 there's
a fairly loose requirement where the
council may require landowners to
prepare stormwater management plans
for their sites
still model management
are a very useful tool and i imagine
they will be used
you know fairly frequently as the spiral
is rolled out to help control
quality of stormwater discharges
however i think there should be some
qualifier or
defined trigger for when one is used
because they are quite expensive
to prepare and to put in place
and
i guess there runs a risk of
one being required in a situation where
it is not needed if the stormwater
quality is of a
adequate quality to be discharged into
the reticulated network and it wouldn't
be required so i wonder that
there would be some
qualifications in terms of quality of
discharge that's coming from the site
and if you're over a trigger limit that
that triggers the requirement for the
stormwater management plan
and then
and i know and i've you know sought
quite a few resource consents for people
from environment south and for
stormwater discharges and they have
a permitted activity role
for stormwater discharges with
a long quite a long list of triggers and
if you achieve all of those
standards then you don't need a resource
consent your water your stormwater
discharge is considered to be suitable
to be discharged
the environment so something along those
lines might be useful in this by-law
just to ensure that people aren't
inadvertently
picked up and having to provide a
stormwater management plan
and that was that was it for me for
comments on the
draft by law okay thank you thank you
megan uh we've got three minutes now for
questions
do we have
no we don't that was a very detailed
report thank you megan
okay right thank you for your submission
thank you very much
see you later
right next we have um peter wilson
federated farmers nz
peter are you
there
welcome i am there welcome peter
so thank you everyone our um submission
on behalf of federated farmers is
relatively um
relatively brief
we're basically um thank you basically
for the opportunity to um to submit
what our main concern is in the bylaw
which is which is for stormwater the
main concern we've got is just the
ability for the um for the bylaw to
inadvertently potentially capture
dischar incidental discharges of an
agricultural nature that would have
occurred otherwise without um without
intent
um we're sort of conscious that
you know i ideally when we looked at
this we thought did you did you need a
by-law at all but you have gone and
written the by-law
all we really wanted to do was just to
find a way to um
ensure that where you've got a small
amount of rural land on the outskirts of
the city within the within the
jurisdiction of the city if there's any
incidental discharges that are happening
out there that somehow find their way
into the stormwater system
without intent
that they couldn't be inadvertently
captured by this bylaw because we've got
other regulatory means to deal with them
and so what i've suggested as a way
without having to rewrite the structure
of the bylaw what i've suggested as a
way to to fix that is to put an
explanatory note into section 6.1 and
6.2
to uh i'm happy to read that out but i
think you've probably got that um
you've probably got that
in your in your notes just
let me know if you don't i can read it
out but um yes just a simple explanatory
note in section 6.1 and 6.2 to um
make it clear that we've got a discharge
of an agricultural nature that would be
reasonably expected to arise in the
course of normal farming practice and
which entered the stormwater system
without intent that wouldn't that
wouldn't breach this bylaw
we're not not encouraging farmers to do
those things and we've got other
regulatory means mainly the
land water plan
um regional plan
to regulate that stuff but um yeah i
don't think that was the intent of this
bylaw to capture that
that that's but that's basically it from
us it's relatively simple facts to a
potential problem
but yeah i'm open to open to questions
okay thanks peter
do we have questions for peter
yes councillor ludlow
thanks peter so just a clarification
then you're really making sure trying to
make sure that
you don't get double caught if there's
an accidental accidental discharge so
exactly
it's accidental it's also incidental so
where there might be a crap stormwater
old stormwater pipe passing under a
piece of rural land there might be some
discharge and drainage coming through
that as well you just we're just trying
to exclude those circumstances i mean by
no means would i condone
a farmer or a rural land owner who
poured discharge or effluent into a
stormwater drain i think you've got
you've got a strong case there um but
this is this is the cases without intent
the accidental and incidental ones
they're captured elsewhere thanks peter
be captured elsewhere
okay further questions anybody
no well that's it peter thank you very
much
no thank you
hopefully hopefully it rains okay
right that takes us next to
[Music]
rebecca blythe
before this starts can i just point out
that i won't be voting because i am the
current chair of town matama
uh okay right um
this is not deliberations we are
receiving submissions i know but just in
case anybody gets confused no thank you
for that
welcome ladies
right which one's rebecca
middle one hi rebecca and do you want to
introduce your friends
and you may take your mask off this
i'm joined and supported by
stevie roblea on my left and
nicki mcrobe on my right
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak to our submission
i just wish to acknowledge
the mere
yourself as cheer and the counsellors
that are here today to listen to us and
thank you for giving us that time
our submission really draws on some of
the things that are very important
to naru nanga
with regard to
water so
naru is seeking a long-term kutukitai
approach to resource management by that
we mean
mountains to the sea and the sea back to
the mountains and that everything is
connected
that is based on a genuine treaty
partnership recognising and providing
for the rights and interests
and values of manafenoua
one of our objectives is to see water
bodies restored to a state of high order
or wellness
whether wherever degradation is present
one of the other very important
principles that we base our focus around
is temana otiway and we see the
stormwater bylaw as part of a package
that works together with a range of
other mechanisms that different entities
are involved in establishing
narunanga strongly supports
the proposed stormwater bylaw and the
purposes of that bylaw
the bylaw will enable the council to
proactively address activities and sites
that are impacting not only councils
stormwater network but water quality in
general
while the health and state of all inner
city waterways are acknowledged as
degraded there are known areas of
specific concern and we have listed out
some of those in our submission
degradation of the waterways in land
negatively impacts on the mana
including collective cultural identity
cultural practices such as mataranga and
mahingakai
naru strongly encourages the council to
allocate funding and resources
alongside the bylaw to enable monitoring
education and remediation directions to
be implemented proactively
and we we have had some very
exciting and productive discussions with
staff
around some of these things
would like the opportunity to work
through risk
prioritization and implementation plans
and are confident this could be part of
our ongoing work together between
tiomarama and invercargill city council
identifying risk and providing for her
order over time
we wish to thank you for this
opportunity again and
i have the support of my colleagues here
for questions that
you may have for us
okay thank you rebecca um
questions
for rebecca
council of ludlow
killer thank you for your um submission
justin around um
the point you've made with regards to
and this is kind of aside from the
submission but the the waterways of
concern
um ottawa by kingsville and the like
have you been working with staff
with
providing suggestions on what can be
done to improve
water quality
yes we have i'll ask my colleague stevie
to address that question
um
take that off so you can hear me
um
so i've been working with
the michael sollet stuff um
for quite a while um since the
um stormwater consent was renewed in
2018 i think and sitting on the
technical review group that's what you
mean with stuff right
and so we've done some um
cultural
maori monitoring um and those
in those streams and had the support of
um staff
alongside with us so we identified the
with window out on out on the ground
about
some of the issues that were there and
provided recommendations back to staff
around what we see is and how they could
be improved
any further questions
yes counselor clark
yeah thank you um
just for the from the presenters um
[Music]
i've lost somebody there
i think we're right are you good to go
you can still hear yeah just for
the presenters um
i guess
raitah will have an opportunity to
develop stormwater further
are you aware that with the three-water
takeover in 2024
there will be a delay of about two years
before they deal or central government
deals with stormwater because it's a
very complex area so
um just
yes i'm signaling that there's further
opportunity for you to have input beyond
just this by the way
that was a good question counselor
claire
cut bye
any further questions
no thanks
or statements disguised as questions
[Laughter]
just trying to be helpful chad no no i
appreciate that no it was it was
actually a good question
a good reminder
[Laughter]
no that's uh thank you very much rebecca
thank you guys
no mickey thank you
next on zoom
we have noel peterson
noel can you hear me
welcome noel
um thank you uh chair
um
i
appreciate the opportunity
uh tennicote guitar um greetings to all
of you
um
i'm not wanting to um
evaluate the work um that's already
recently done
in the uh stormwater area and in what's
underway i
i see lots of it going on around the
city and that's really good to see
um but i'm wanting to um
to see a um an expansion of the um
stormwater
um policy within um in the cargo city
council
um to look further into the um
the the issues of um
stormwater in relation to
flooding and
the environment in in
the effects of climate change
and uh i hope that you've um been given
some additional notes that i send along
um
earlier in the day um
if you have that's that's good um i
won't um
drown on through um talking about those
but i would like to underscore
uh the climate change issue in
particular
um we need to um
show some political will um to
actually take some action on the matter
um and i i
just
listening to professor renwick today on
radio new zealand
i'm saying that the twine was actually
becoming particularly tight
to do something about it and you might
ask
what can we do about it well there's a
whole lot of options on the first thing
is to actually open the discussion and
talk about it and that's why i'm here
today actually
bringing that up
and
i um
i think that
instead of me going on i'll just uh ask
if there's any uh
further questions other than that
just remember um there was a director
from central government some time back
and that we need to take climate change
mitigation into all the decisions that
we make in councils
so um yeah i'll just leave it open there
uh for questions thank you
thank you noel uh questions council
counselor
thanks noel um i guess your submission
speaks to an issue that's being faced by
quite a few councils around new zealand
at the moment with
those inundation events that uh
um unseasonable
uh higher than normal and and more
frequent
um
to
what level of um
of variation of the standards do you
suggest that we apply the bylaw to
um well it depends on
council of oddly um
on which way you're looking at it and i
guess you're focusing on the flash flood
events and so that's like
i would um
like to think that um council staff
council officers on the drainage
department actually have a fairly good
angle on where the priorities would be
and and i guess um it can expand that to
um every uh
great
stormwater great in the city if you've
got enough funding for it and that's uh
i did suggest you know there's three
waters uh half a billion dollars
being off about 32 councils
and at this very moment and maybe
there's an opportunity there
to um to actually look at that um yeah i
hope that answers your question
thanks noel
further questions for noel
uh that being the case noel thank you
very much for your submission
oh sorry council lush i'm just giving a
thumbs up right
okay no thank you no
mommy thank you we'll talk to you again
thank you
we moved now to
in the chamber becky henry
yeah we are we are affectionately
oh he's just going to treat you
i wonder if anyone can try and get
so yeah
yeah that's a good idea
thanks thank you thanks
yep thank you welcome vicky
so you're most welcome to remove the
mask if you wish yeah cool yeah just
what i'm talking about yeah yeah that's
fine and just bring the microphone
closer to you yeah
right
perfect
right
oh good um
and greetings to your british at the
mayor councillors and council staff
um thanks for the opportunity to talk
about stormwater
i don't have a vested interest in
stormwater
and i don't have an income that relies
on discharging pollutants i'm just an
average homeowner with a strong concern
for the environment
and i see some ways to improve the
outcomes
so while it's really good to see this
being addressed when i read through the
bio it kind of felt like a box-ticking
exercise
i kind of think we've missed a real
opportunity to link this to
a broader strategic vision for
stormwater
the bylaw covers the required minimums
but it stops there
so by establishing a strategic
stormwater management plan
we can link it to roading parks and
reserves
asset management and building consents
and this along with council adopting
best practice within its own activities
the council will be making a powerful
water protection move
even better if it's linked to a
sustainability policy
but i haven't seen that policy
if part of a wider strategy stormwater
treatment options can be introduced
as part of new capital works or during
operational or maintenance work
and as an add-on to a wider project
cost savings efficiencies and good
stormwater outcomes are achieved or not
being the core purpose of the project
this can include rain gardens
and swales being retrofitted during
roading and pipe upgrades
stormwater linked to writing means that
council can establish best practice
procedures for maintaining roads and
bridges
in a way that reduces polluted runoff
from entering surface waters
priorities should be given to runoff
management and sensitive watersheds or
where there's a threat to water quality
as well as high traffic and breaking
areas
rows of slopes that are prone to water
to water discharge
reserves management practices can be
reviewed for anything that could
contribute to the degradation of water
quality
and that includes maintenance regimes
spray and fertilizer use
and the introduction introduction of
stormwater management devices
and that slow flow and reduce the
contaminant loading
and done well this can be very
attractive
council can introduce rain gardens green
roofs swales
and rainwater tanks and council property
and riparian planting to urban waterways
and this can be done in conjunction with
flood protection
without compromising any safety
we can protect stormwater discharges
into rivers by having pollution nets
over the outlets
and this has the potential to remove
significant volumes of plastic from our
waterways
not only does council have to own its
own behavioural impacts you can also
encourage positive behaviour by
businesses and homeowners
by looking at rates and lower consent
fees for installing rainwater tanks
permeable surfaces
stormwater retention edges to car parks
and for establishing wetland and
riparian planting or any other low
impact features
actively encourage the use of stormwater
management devices that don't just
reduce the runoff but also improve the
quality of the water
my land has an underground river and a
surface creek that discharge into the
waikiwi and anything that we do will
impact on this already much polluted
river
we are reintroducing wetlands and
planting extensively to protect the
creek mitigate the pollution
and we're building as sustainably and as
low impact as we can
yet there's no difference in how council
treat me versus my neighbours who
aren't doing these things and some of
them are
harming the waterways through some of
their land use
surely this can be improved
i think by council leading the way with
an integrated approach to stormwater
across all activities and assets
by enforcing a new bylaw
and by encouraging positive behaviours
through consent and raids this could be
a very powerful step forwards in water
protection
so let's not just tick that box let's
lead
there is such an opportunity here to
encourage positive behaviour that leads
to water quality improvements and that's
got to be a win for everybody
thank
you thanks vicky um
gonna open up for questions
consoles
no questions
great
thank you very much all right sorry
slow to get the hand up don't worry
vicky it's not a toughie um i guess one
of the questions that we would ask is
given
the potential change around water
governance coming
um
your suggestion is why wait for that
start now absolutely right
that's just what i was wanting to
clarify because it would be easy for us
to go
yeah just hedge it at this time and
every day there's pollution in our water
that we can mitigate we need to act now
there's no time for waiting
your message around leadership sir thank
you thank you yeah miss
i just want to say uh thank you very
much you've got some lovely
great ideas in there oh
thank you sort of thank you appreciate
that thanks for listening
right vicky i think yeah pretty good
lovely thank you everyone thanks for
tuning in
right that leaves us with one more and
that is philip brown
um
um
yep
mr brown welcome
hi hi everyone
thanks for having me
okay far away yep good
excellent
okay
all right hi everyone thanks for giving
me the opportunity to speak today
um hopefully you're not too tired at the
end of the day so i'll try and keep this
relatively
short and sweet
so my name is phil brown i'm a planner
working for foresight consulting
and i submitted on the
bylaw for the fuel companies which is
mobile bp and z energy
the submission focused on a number of
key issues that the bylaw
might pose for discharges from fuel
industry sites
so today i really want to talk briefly
about two key matters um
the importance of providing a regulated
pathway for appropriately managed fuel
industry discharges and secondly
the stormwater management plan process
as it's set out
in the bylaw
so i've actually had a look at
icc's initial feedback
on the fuel company's submission which
was contained in the agenda for this
meeting
in
the council's comments they acknowledge
the role of the ministry for environment
guidelines for discharges
and that it ensures discharges from
petroleum industry sites
are of an acceptable quality and uh icc
also state that discharges that have
passed through
an appropriate treatment device should
be able to
enter the stormwater network
so the other interesting thing was that
icc indicated that
they intend to release a bylaw guidance
document which will
address these
ministry for environment
discharge guidelines
and this approaches is supported by the
fuel companies
and the fuel companies also would accept
icc's position not to include references
to specific industry standards in the
by-law
um
however
the the only point that i make is that
it's critically important to provide a
regulated activity pathway
for you know discharges that do pass
through a stormwater management device
so i think that
key to this and and it would be great if
the guidance document addresses mfe
guidelines but i think the other aspect
of it is just ensuring that
the wording of clause 6.1 which is the
regulated activities
[Music]
i think you've just frozen phil
um yeah and then so really on to my
second point and final point is just in
terms of the
stormwater management plan
submission process
the fuel companies are not opposed to
the requirement
of submitting us an smp as part of the
bylaw
approval process
but the requirement to for a suitably
qualified and experienced professional
to undertake
an assessment of contaminated soils as
part of this process
is considered to be a bit of an
overreach
and it's not really something that we've
seen in other by-laws
for example
tauranga and palmerston north stormwater
bylaws they include a stormwater
management plan process
but neither of them require an
assessment of underlying soils
so i think
in terms of that if it's considered
necessary to to include this requirement
in the smp process it would be good if
the clause was worded to clarify that it
applies in situations where
the runoff from exposed areas
of soil is likely to enter the
stormwater network so for example you
know if stormwater
runs over abundant and controlled
impervious area before it is
appropriately managed and discharged
it's not going to come into contact with
exposed soils and so it's it's not
necessary to assess the quality of the
soils in those situations
and just finally
i mentioned that i'm supportive of icc's
suggestion of releasing a bylaw guidance
document
because this will really help clarify
any
sort of areas of uncertainty
it would be
particularly helpful in my view of
public feedback on this document was
invited prior to its implementation um
and then this would just provide an
opportunity to fulfill the input on the
process and really
just ensure everyone's on the same page
so
with that i'll i'll leave it there
thanks for listening to me today i'd be
pleased to send through
an email just outlining the kind of key
points that i've made today that would
assist
um and yeah i'm happy to answer any
questions from the committee now okay
thanks phillip look um we had a slight
glitch there and you froze for a brief
it was right on your first point you
made the last two points
can you just go back over that first
point
yeah sure um
that i believe that was
uh so so i was just saying
yes um so
so that the approach to release a
guidance document which addresses mfe
guidelines that's
fully supported
and it would be really useful uh the
fuel company also accept
icc's position not to include
specific
reference to industries in the by-law um
so so that
that's fine but i think it's critically
important to provide a regulated
activity pathway for discharges that do
pass through a stormwater management
device um so my point around clause 6.1
was i think that clause which is the
regulated activity clause could be
amended so that it um you know clearly
it provides a pathway through that
clause for discharges that pass through
a storm water management device prior to
entering the network
okay
thanks for that
right i'm going to open up the questions
council unlocked thanks chair uh thanks
for your submission phil um i've got two
questions the first one comes from
[Music]
a position of ignorance
so and it's not facetious but could you
explain to me what
is an appropriately managed fuel
industry discharge please
yeah sure no that's not a
um not a dumb question at all so
basically
uh buy appropriately managed so
what i've been referring to a lot and i
talked about it in the submission um was
at these fuel industry sites they're
subject to the
ministry for environment
discharges
guidance documents and so in that
guidance document really what it sets
out is that
the expectation at service station sites
and terminals is that
um
at-risk areas where this sort of storing
uh hydrocarbons or there's um
people using them or filling up their
cars and that sort of thing
in these areas it's necessary for them
to be
to have an impervious surface underlying
it and for discharges to be funded and
to be filtered into a management device
and so the management device there's all
sorts of expectations around that um so
they're called separators or
interceptors whereby
you know they'll
separate out hydrocarbons and total
suspended solids and then so it passes
through that and then the mfv set
guidelines for what these
interceptors need to treat to before
they then enter the network and so
so that's the whole process by which
a site has appropriately managed
discharges yep thanks phil that's that's
really useful that's reminded me of the
context
um
you were talking about the
the fact that we may produce a list of
guidelines alongside the byte law which
might be helpful and suggesting that we
consult with some stakeholders are there
any examples of those guidelines being
used by councils elsewhere
yeah that's interesting because i
i don't think i've seen it before i mean
i could i could um you know look into it
and see if that's been done before and
i'd be happy to do that and um
send through any examples if i can find
them if that would assist um so i'm not
aware of that being done before but i
think it's a you know i think it's a
good idea
thank you
okay further questions
uh there are no further questions philip
thank you for that
thanks guys
see ya
see you later
right that brings us to the end of the
submissions for the stormwater bylaw so
i like to end
this meeting and we and the officers
report oh sorry the officers report um
i believe you've got an officer's report
on the front of that agenda
summary of submission sorry
recommendations
yeah
the recommendations
that we received the report
um
we received the submissions made on
consultation
and note this
summary of the submissions here from the
submitters which you've done
and we note the next stage of process
which will be the deliberations on may 3
to consider the information received and
deliberate on final recommendations
to council ahead of any final adoption
of the stormwater plan to have someone
move those recommendations please moved
councillor scout
seconded councillor amundsen i'm going
to put those recommendations all those
in favor all right
again
they are carry
and and we've noticed your extension
thank you now that ends that meeting and
we are now going to
reconvene
can i just check mr chair so that's the
end of a public meeting
we'll reconvene the public excluded and
i think that might mean that live
streaming concludes and can we just make
sure that the sufficient time that we
retain the zoom capability
just
okay
do we need to re-zoom in on the other
meeting no no i don't believe so but
just
you